let's go to five headlines
[Music]
well we begin of course with the trump
supporter in portland apparently
executed in cold blood on sunday um
saturday that is a caravan of trump
supporters
and blue lives matter supporters went
into portland to counter demonstrate
much has been made of the fact that they
were shooting paintballs at the blm and
antifa people using pepper spray in some
cases and that's true
but every video i've seen of the
paintball and pepper spray being
deployed
begins with someone in the antifa slash
blm crowd throwing something at them or
using some other weapon against them so
in any case it was a volatile
environment
and then the shooting the victim's name
is aaron danielson the man
police are investigating for the killing
is michael forrest reinel
um a few pieces of footage have emerged
from this none of them very clear
the first shows you know in the distance
in the dark one man walk up to another
and then you see the gun go off and the
guy who pulled the trigger runs in the
other direction
it does not appear at all to be
self-defense in that video
it appears to be execution plain and
simple but the most revealing
video is actually one that doesn't
doesn't show the shooting at all
um instead it's what you hear that
matters i'm gonna play that for you now
and uh
again you're not gonna be able to really
see anything it doesn't matter what you
see
just just listen listen for the words
that you hear
[Music]
yeah that is one of the most chilling
videos i've ever seen and it doesn't
even
show uh the shooting itself you can
clearly hear someone say hey we've got
another one here
we've got another one we we've got
another one here we've got someone right
here and then and then someone else says
right here and then bang bang you hear
the guns um
by all indications they targeted this
man
and executed him in cold blood first
degree murder and political terrorism
um and you know the guy who did it
should be should be
this should be federal charges ship them
off to guantanamo bay as far as i'm
concerned
he is not only a murderer but a
terrorist this is an act of terrorism
now needless to say the the leftists who
are
apoplectic about kyle rittenhouse in
spite of the fact that it appeared in
his case to actually be self-defense
they couldn't find it in themselves to
condemn this this political execution
with nearly the same fervor or or really
condemn it at all in a lot of cases
um this includes of course the rotting
cucumber of a mayor ted wheeler
who spent more time in his press
conference yesterday condemning
donald trump than the actual guy who
pulled the trigger
and also joe biden who issued a
statement that really flies in the face
of all the stuff
we hear about him being a decent guy and
just a wonderful guy the
the democrat convention was just four
days of what a wonderful great guy he is
what here are
his his favorite ice cream toppings what
a great guy he is
um well you see not just in this but you
see
uh illustrated in this statement which
i'll read to in a second
the fact that joe biden is among other
things
an incredible moral coward so let me
play this for or not play it uh let me
read it for you in fact
here's the statement from joe biden
uh this statement by the way of course
is being praised by the media as being
just a wonderful wonderful statement
very calming and and all of that
great leadership here well you tell me
what you think
the deadly violence we saw overnight in
portland is unacceptable
shooting in the streets of a great
american city is unacceptable oh he
called it
well it's unacceptable great okay well
that's a strong condemnation isn't it
yes um uh walking up to a guy and
executing him on the street is
unacceptable
i condemn this violence unequivocally i
condemn violence of every kind by anyone
whether on the left or right
and i challenge donald trump to do the
same it does not matter if you find the
political views of your opponents
abhorrent
any loss of life is a tragedy today
there is another family grieving in
america and jill and i offer our dubious
condolences
we must not become a country at war with
ourselves a country that accepts the
killing of fellow americans who do not
agree with you
a country that vows vengeance towards
one another but this is the america that
president trump wants us to be the
america he believes we are as a country
we must condemn the incitement of hate
and resentment that led to this deadly
clash
listen to that part let me read it again
as a country we must condemn the
incitement of hate and resentment that
led to this
deadly clash it is not a peaceful
protest when you go out spoiling for a
fight
who does president trump what does
president trump think will happen when
he continues to insist on fanning the
flames of hate and division in our
society
and using the politics of fear to whip
up his supporters he is recklessly
encouraging the violence
uh and then he goes on a little bit more
uh attack just the rest of it is just
attacking president trump okay so
he spends most of this um condemning
president trump
there there i i don't i don't think
there is even in this statement really
a clear and very specific and harsh
condemnation of the killing
itself he calls it unacceptable but he
does it in the
he's using a passive voice which is a
common trick that leftists are pulling
now and we'll get we'll get to another
example of that in just a second
but he's using a passive voice and he's
kind of speaking in general oh deadly
a clash a deadly clash this wasn't a
clash
it wasn't a dead the deadly moment was
not a clash this was just a guy walking
on the street he was shot in the head
uh it's not a clash that's that's murder
and uh and but he's condemning the
incitement and hate and resentment that
led to this
now yeah i agree that there's a lot of
incitement and hate and resentment
leading to this
but that's happening from blm and antifa
and and democrats and i know that you
know
i basically just said the same thing
three times sorry for the redundancy
that's happening from them but that's
not what he means he's saying the people
that were there
were inciting the hatred and uh
and and resentment so this is this is
victim blaming on top of it
um at a minimum this is moral cowardice
from joe biden
who just i'm sorry is not the great
decent guy
uh that they make him out to be i wish
he was
i really wish he was but he's not
um number two since we're on the subject
of the impossibility of policing these
days here are a few exhibits to present
for your consideration
uh not that you need any more we've seen
a lot but just some some of the latest
okay on that topic first this is a blm
leader in dc
openly calling for police and other
public officials to be murdered
and this is being said into a megaphone
in the middle of the city
um and uh anyway take a listen
i'm at the point where i'm ready to put
these police in the [ __ ] grave
[Music]
i'm at the point where i want to burn
the
white house down
i want to take it to the senators i want
to take it to the congress
i want to take the fight to them and at
the end of the day
if they ain't going to hear us we burn
them
i'm one that talk real [ __ ] i'm talking
in new york
and i'm talking in dc
the same way i police up in new york
cops up here in d.c
the same way i bust police in the head
in new york i bust police in the head in
d.c
[Music]
now it's a lot of people and i'm gonna
be honest
it's a lot of people that's on this
front line and one of the things that i
always say
don't give on this front line if you
ain't gonna [ __ ] fight
don't get on this front line if you
ain't gonna take no hit
don't get on this front line when the
police can push up you push back
if you won't be on this front line and
the racist
nasty punk [ __ ] police is pushing up
you push the [ __ ] up what you just heard
there
um none of that is free speech that is
terrorism
incitement but you want to talk about
incitement that that's what incitement
sounds like
and if we didn't have such a feckless
and useless government
that person would have been arrested on
the spot and would be headed to federal
prison right now
again that is terrorism and then and
then there's this from cnn uh we talked
about the passive voice well here you go
here's their headline in caption on
twitter it says
two chicago police officers pulled over
a person suspected of having a gun
and all three ended up hospitalized with
gunshot wounds officials say
so all three ended up hospitalized how
did that happen
did bullets fall out of the sky randomly
how do they all end up with gunshot
wounds
what do you mean they ended up well
turns out and you would have to read
like five or six
paragraphs into this article to see it
turns out the officers tried to pull the
guy over because he's committed
committing a crime allegedly and he shot
them both the suspect did
then a third police officer rushed into
the scene to save those officers and
shot
the suspect that's what happened but
even in the reporting
of a violent criminal shooting police
cnn
has to find a way to make it seem like
police at least share part of the blame
or maybe that no one is to blame
so enemy of the people yes these are the
cnn is these are
enemies of the people it's perhaps one
of the maybe the truest thing that trump
has ever said in his life
um describing the american media as an
enemy of the people
i mean they are they're trying to get
the american people many american people
killed
i mean they want to race war they want
violence and chaos and
murder in the street it's what they want
i cannot think of any other
way to explain this
i mean when you can't even bring
yourself to just just straight up report
violent criminal shoots police officers
you can't even do that
number three big shock over the weekend
uh another big shock it was a weekend of
a lot of
shocking events none of them good
unfortunately um so another one it was
announced that chadwick boseman who
starred in black panther also played
jackie robinson james brown played a
he had quite a quite a filmography in a
relatively short career
uh he has died of cancer colon cancer
apparently he was diagnosed back in
um i think it was 2018 and he never
i believe he never told anyone publicly
about his diagnosis
and he went on making movies and uh and
doing press visiting sick children in
hospital uh you know
carrying on being a public figure a
celebrity without ever letting on that
he was dying of cancer which is a really
remarkable
thing i think it's a great example of um
of courage and dignity
um and it reminds me of a story when i
when i read about this i immediately
thought of a story
that i think i've mentioned before in
the gulag archipelago soldier easton's
book about the soviet um labor camp
system
and one story he tells us a lot of
stories that really stick out but but
one in particular about um
a guy who's who's uh in one of these
prison camps
scheduled to be executed uh but he
convinces the guards
to let his wife visit so he can see his
wife one last time before he's killed
but the deal is that he's not allowed to
tell his wife
that he's going to be executed so he can
spend a couple days with her but he
can't tell her anything
and probably telling her would put her
own life in jeopardy so he spends a
weekend with her
you know and uh he never lets on and she
never suspects anything and then as soon
as she leaves they take him before the
firing squad
so this is you know a similar kind of
thing a man facing down his own
mortality experiencing presumably an
incredible amount of inner anguish and
grief and
fear and panic and everything yet
carrying on with dignity and
quiet resolve so heartbreaking but a
great example
um for us all
let's go number four
i regret to inform you my friends that
michelle obama
uh former first lady wealthy powerful
admired loved famous
is nonetheless oppressed and she's
oppressed by you
it turns out so you know shame on you
for oppressing someone who's 100 times
richer and more powerful than you
how dare you in a recent podcast the
former first lady according to the new
york post this is what she said
telling her tale of oppression she says
what i've been completely incognito
during the eight years in the white
house walking the dogs on the canal
people will come up and pet my dogs but
will not look me in the eye
they don't know it's me what white folks
don't understand is like
that it's it's like that is so telling
of how white america views people who
are not like
them you know we don't exist and when we
do exist we exist as a threat
and that's exhausting what the white
community doesn't understand about being
a person of color in this nation is that
there are daily slights in our
workplaces where people talk over you or
people don't even see you and then later
on she says we were stopping to get ice
cream and i had told the secret service
to stand
back because we were trying to be normal
trying to go in when i'm just a black
woman i noticed that white people don't
even see me
i'm standing there with two black little
black girls another black female adult
they're in soccer uniforms and a white
woman cuts right in front of us
like she didn't even see us the girl
behind the counter almost took the order
and i had to stand up and was like well
i'm not gonna cause a scene with
michelle obama um
she continues so i stepped up and said i
don't know what that means
anyway she said i stepped up and said
excuse me you don't see us four people
standing right here
you just jumped in line obama said the
woman didn't apologize she never looked
me in the eye she didn't know it was me
all she saw was a black person or a
group of black people or maybe she
didn't even see that
because we were that invisible okay
you know perhaps it never has occurred
to michelle that actually she's in no
position
to tell other groups of people what they
do and don't understand
she says this about three times in this
one you know
in in two minutes of talking she's about
three times she's a what white people
don't understand
what you white people don't realize
it it's pretty disturbing that this
woman and her husband
were in charge of the country
and had this attitude about
you know about a vast majority of the
american population
based on this she has a very low opinion
of white people
and a you know white person cuts in
front of her immediately assumes it's
racist
so how the hell do you know what other
people
are thinking or feeling michelle how do
you know
who are you to go around saying this you
have no freaking idea
what other people are doing or what
their motivations are or what's going on
in their head
who are you to assume that she just
paddles off you know a dozen things that
white people think and don't think and
do and don't do
she's doing exactly what she accuses
white people doing to her
by not letting them exist and be real
and be their own people and speak for
themselves no she's going to speak for
them
um the arrogance of that is just i mean
it's off the richter scale
it's one of the most arrogant people in
the country is michelle obama and i'm
not just saying that based on on only
this this is this is part of a pattern
with her meanwhile the traumatic
experiences that she recounts getting
cut you know cut in front of in line
people not being overly friendly
getting talked over that happens to
everyone michelle
that's a normal thing for people it
happens to me
it happens to every person on earth
that is an utterly normal part of life
for
everyone okay we all deal with that
all of us i could tell you stories of
having people cut in front of me in line
it's happened to me i guarantee you that
you know what i didn't do though i
didn't assume that the person doing it
was it was a bigot or i didn't make
these these
damning assumptions about their entire
life and existence and everything based
on that
i assume that they either just didn't
see me because they weren't paying
attention they're up in their own head
and it's nothing racial or bigoted at
all or worst case scenario i assume that
you know in this moment this person's
acting like kind of a jerk
doesn't mean that they're a horrible
person elsewhere i've done it myself i
bet you have too michelle
i bet there have been times when you've
cut in front of people knowingly or
unknowingly
so we all deal with that okay all of us
all of that stuff oh i got talked over
that that happens to everyone it is so
normal it's not we don't like it it's
not fun
it's annoying it is so normal though i i
can't stress this enough
it just happens to everyone all the time
it really does i promise you that
and and rather than making assumptions
about entire races of people
and telling white people what they do
and don't experience why don't you ask
them you know why don't you why don't
you let them speak for themselves
and tell you what they experience so you
you have something that happens to you
every once in a while you get cut in
front of in line
someone talks over you rather than
assuming oh this never happens to any
anyone of that race maybe ask them oh
does this happen to you guys
and if they tell you yes then just take
them at their word
um but here's the deal michelle obama
you know she said she's pretending she
wants to be treated just like everybody
else no
she wants the opposite she doesn't want
she's offended that she was treated like
everybody else
she doesn't want that she's offended not
to be treated differently under the
guise of being
being offended that she was treated
differently that's what this is really
about that's what this is always about
i mean with this with this kind of thing
um
okay so especially when it's a
privileged rich
powerful wealthy person claiming that
they're being oppressed
uh in 99 times out of 100
what they're really going to be offended
about when you get down into it is just
that
they you know god forbid got treated
like a normal person once
okay number five the vmas were last
night i somehow completely missed that
uh they were on i usually watch all the
vmas i'm a big fan of you know i host a
watch party uh usually
uh when the vmas are on we all wear our
pajamas and dance to the to the songs
um it's a fun time in any case the
hollywood reporter has the recap
uh first of all there's a picture of
lady gaga accepting her award
for her performance in the latest uh
power rangers film it looks like she
does look she looks
like a villain from power rangers
doesn't she a little bit or maybe mortal
kombat
um anyway the hollywood reporter says
kiki palmer hosted the show which aired
sunday night the weekend
one video of the year for blinding
lights at sundays actually it's spelled
i think it's misspelled because it's
missing an e
for the weekend it's really spelled
weekend
the weekend uh one video of the year
other winners sunday night included lady
gaga and ariana grande
uh bts taylor swift h-e-r maluma
machine gun kelly and megan the stallion
i don't know who any of these people are
i know taylor swift and lady gaga those
two i know uh grande she's the one who
licked the donut she's the donut
licorice i know her
h.e.r and maluma what
um these these
they sound like uh skin conditions a
little bit gaga's other wins included
artist of the year and song of the year
for rain on me her collaboration with
ariana grande
uh the weeknd also won best rmb
um kiki palmer host of the show blah
blah blah
she'll see if there's any big okay here
we go later on in the show palmer showed
off her comedic chops
by portraying her alter egos including
one she's featured on her tick tock
while visiting different spots in new
york such as the bronx zoo where she
uh could see the quote the cats from the
womp video
i guess that's supposed to be a joke
that's her showing off her comedic jobs
uh palmer encounters her southern belle
alter ego lady miss
at one point she jokes you're cattier
than carol baskin
oh man this is bad
you're cattier than carol baskin
that was actually a joke that made it
into this
professional production
oh man i i i you know i i went when i
was in seventh grade
my school had a talent show and there
was like an eleven-year-old who got up
and did a stand-up performance
and all of his material was way better
than your cattier than carol basket so
unfortunately i i i'm sad i missed that
show we all we all missed it um
you might say there are more important
things going on in the world i don't
know well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt walsh show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content